[Musique]
vous avez soutenu la guerre en irak
avant l'invasion
c'est faux je n'ai pas soutenu la guerre
en et 2002 en fait tu te trompes a
soutenu l'intervention en irak avant
qu'elle ne commence et il a fallu
attendre plus d'un an après pour qu'ils
changent de position qui n'a ni le look
ni l'endurance absolument pas
l'endurance est nécessaire pour être
présidente de notre pays
joe mendes da manha quand il aura voyagé
dans 112 qui négocier un accord à cesser
le feu
la libération de six ans et ouvert de
nouvelles opportunités dans l'une est
même passé entre eux a témoigné devant
le congrès il pourra me parler dandurand
acclamé par ses supporters hier soir à
new york
donald trump effectué sa première sortie
depuis le scandale de ses propos
sexistes révélé dans une vidéo
je suis automatiquement attirés par les
belles femmes je les embrasse tout de
suite c'est comme un aimant les ombrages
n'attend pas quand on est une star elle
nous laisse faire on fait tout ce qu'on
veut je prends que the dog
il m'a dit j'ai fait des choses que je
regrette les mots publiés aujourd'hui
datent depuis dix ans fait partie des
cheminots faith en arrivant ils ne se
sont même pas serré la main et de la
deuxième question du débat la polémique
du week end entre en jeu près où la
pensée violet
une femme en se basant sur leur
apparence relais de la cendre à 10 par
quand je vois te parler je me dis que le
populisme c'est pas la défense du peuple
contrairement à ce que réclament
toujours tous les populistes c'est le
mépris du peuple car je ne suis pas fier
de ce que j'ai dit mais c'était quelque
chose qui s'est passé si vous regardez
bien
clinton il s'est comporté beaucoup plus
mal que moi par quelques minutes avant
ce deuxième débat
le milliardaire a donné une conférence
de presse autour de lui plusieurs femmes
qui affirment avoir été violées par
l'ancien président des états unis
j'entends de tels propos ça me rappelle
le conseil de mon amie michelle obama
quand il frappe en dessous de la
ceinture il faut frapper au dessus 9 600
deux types political campaign
je n'ai jamais vu j'espère bien une
politique aussi ça le travail
j'espère bien que jamais une campagne
française de tombera à ce niveau digne
menée par ce troisième et dernier débat
présidentiel constituait l'ultime chance
pour donald trump de combler son retard
sur hillary clinton dans les sondages à
leur arrivée les deux candidats ne se
serre pas la main par les respecte
manadou élections donald trump robert
clinton selon un sondage pour la chaîne
nbc news
un rebondissement ils entendent
inattendue alors que la démocrate est
visé par un nouveau scandale wikileaks
révèle en effet que la candidate
démocrate a été pré
mieux à l'avance des questions posées
lors d'un débat de la primaire démocrate
voir comment peut-elle être encore
candidat imaginez si ça avait été moi
qui avais fait ça qu'est ce qui me
serait arrivé
la chaise électrique finale aux états
unis donald trump a traversé cinq états
pour faire cinq meetings tout ça en une
seule journée
le vieil ne va finalement pas poursuivre
hillary clinton dans la sphère des
emails qui empoisonnent sa campagne
depuis des mois elle est protégée par un
système corrompu affirme-t-il c'est un
système totalement corrompu ça fait
longtemps que je le dis vous ne pouvez
pas analysé six cent cinquante mille
nouveaux e-mails l'envi jours voir
barack obama vient même en renfort et
aux la moquerie au sujet du candidat
républicain
privé de son compte twitter par ses
conseillers pour éviter les dérapages
si quelqu'un n'est pas capable de
maîtriser son compte twitter alors qu'en
sera-t-il pour les codes nucléaires
l'élection de tron serait un drame un
drame pour le monde parce que cet homme
est proprement irresponsable et que mes
mots je vous vois seriez donc ils
arrivent ils représentent tout ce que
vous combattez de verser je ne suis pas
américain
alors ce serait l'apocalypse annoncée
selon votre âme ce serait un immense
risque ce serait des zones mais de toute
façon c'est déshonorant pour les états
unis qu un histrion comme ça atteignent
45 % ça interpelle beaucoup pour ce qui
était supposé être la plus belle
démocratie du monde voire se trouve que
si madame clinton l'emportent ce n'est
pas si rose que ce qu'on nous dit mais
mme clinton c'est la candidate qui veut
faire passer le traité transatlantique
le taffetas vous savez on a fait passer
malheureusement le traitaient que le
canada là ce serait le traité du boeuf
aux hormones des ogm le taffetas elle l
est pour tromper contre les politiciens
corrompus et leurs intérêts particuliers
ont régné sur ce pays depuis trop
longtemps
aujourd'hui c'est notre fête de
l'indépendance noir ne fait pas d'erreur
nos valeurs fondamentales sont en jeu
dans ce scrutin marque les deux
candidats seront à new york pour la
soirée électorale
c'est aussi ici qu'ils ont tous les deux
voté ce matin donald trump aux alentours
de 11h hillary clinton
un petit peu plus tôt vers 8h30
l'arithmétique des minorités devrait lui
donner la victoire mais c'est pas tout à
fait sûr parce que elle a quand même
fait beaucoup de gens là des tests en
vérité pas franchement tout ce qu'ils
voulaient
les âneries la brutalité tous que ce
type peut sortir et crème
invraisemblable donc je voterai quand
même pour hillary clinton mais met en
effet tout ce qu'elle représente mais
assez détestable plein de super nerveux
mais plutôt enthousiaste c'est une
immense opportunité à quelques minutes
près il n'aura pas vu ses militantes
féministes seins nus floutés par la télé
américaine
elles sont venues dans le bureau de vote
du candidat républicain dénoncé sa
misogynie la liste des des promesses et
des malédictions d'ailleurs de donald
trump allez juste considérable des
malédictions pour vous ce sera une
malédiction s'il était élu demain à
écouter ça poserait un d'abord cela nous
poserait un problème majeur à nous
européens prise états unis la france et
d'une longue histoire rien entre nous le
lien du sang des jeunes américains sont
morts pour notre liberté
jamais on peut l'oublier car je fais
confiance au peuple américain pour
savoir quel est le choix qui correspond
le mieux aux valeurs aux principes à la
liberté à cette relation avec la france
est avec l'europe
françois hollande le président de la
république a regardé le début de la
soirée électorale à paris et maintenant
il est allé se coucher il dort mais un
de ses plus proches conseillers doit le
réveiller par téléphone dès que les
résultats de l'élection américaine sont
connus et c'est un new york est la ville
de donald trump la terre d'élection
d'hillary clinton que les deux candidats
à passent leurs soirées électorales à
deux kilomètres l'un de l'autre c'est au
javits center que la démocrate prépare
son discours un centre de congrès aux
airs de grandes verrières possible
probable clin d'oeil au plafond de verre
qu'elle entend briser ce soir hillary
clinton
moi j'étais hier à philadelphie avec les
familles obama et les familles clinton
parce qu'il y avait barack et michelle
obama et hillary et bill clinton et même
chelsea clinton et on avait franchement
l'impression que c'était bon ça y est on
a gagné on peut se le dit
bravo bienvenue dans le club il arrive
donc il est allé se coucher en pensant
que hillary clinton allait gagner
largement
eh ben pour l'instant visiblement c'est
pas le cas donc il risque d'avoir une
surprise en se réveillant par clinton
est donné vainqueur dans virginie et
dans le colorado ça fait 22 grands
électeurs pour ces deux états donc c'est
important mais est à tomber pour
l'instant c'est plutôt il tombe dans
l'escarcelle de donald trump
effectivement est le dernier en date
c'est donc l'eau aia et l'ohio l'un de
ces états clés qu'on attendait avec
énormément d'impatience car il a du
poids regardez ce qu'a twitté tout à
l'heure hillary clinton
quel que soit l'âge quel que soit le
scénario de ce soit merci pour tout ça
sent pas bon la victoire quand même
quand on lance victoire également de
donald trump dans le missouri
avec dix grands électeurs pour cet état
là du côté d'hillary clinton à la traîne
donc pour l'instant victoire au nouveau
mexique
cinq grands électeurs victoire également
de la candidate démocrate dans le
connecticut doigts
c'est une joie intense une onde de choc
un coup de tonnerre hier soir j'ai
félicité donald trump et j'ai lui a
proposé de travailler avec lui pour
notre pays
j'espère qu'il sera un bon président
pour tous les américains
je promets à chaque citoyen de notre
pays que je serai le président de tous
les américains
un moment difficile dans les relations
entre l'europe et les nations unies
non les états unis mais le président
américain est librement élu et mérite le
respect de l'institution européenne ce
prix là aussi en face de lui la réalité
et c'est un homme d'affaires
la réalité il sait composer avec elle et
il sera donc s'adapter évoluer tirer les
leçons changé pour la cellule
diplomatique de l'elysée avait pris
depuis de longs mois
contact avec les équipes d'hillary
clinton mais pas vraiment avec celle de
donald trump
c'est une non pas vraiment une surprise
mais c'était une possibilité
j'ai ce sentiment lorsque je me suis
rendu à plusieurs reprises ces temps ci
aux états unis et françois hollande a
même eu des mots très durs à l'encontre
de donald trump confiant je cite que il
n'a jamais que le milliardaire américain
lui donnait je cite le hall coeur près
ces débats très imprudent de la part du
chef de l'état d'avoir de telles
critiques pendant la campagne doit
coûter je crois qu'il n'a pas été le
seul d'abord un parc devons regarder en
face cette situation
et là encore prendre conscience des
inquiétudes qui sont provoquées par les
désordres du monde dans tous les peuples
y compris le peuple américain c'est le
plus beau coup de pied au cul qu'on
puisse donner au monde des bobos des
médias de la politique des sondages le
peuple américain a parlé
sachons nous aussi on tirait maintenant
toutes les conséquences
félicitations au nouveau président des
états unis donald trump et au peuple
américain libre marine le pen qui veut
voir dans cette élection inattendue
un bon présage pour elle-même part qu'il
faudra que la france et l'europe soit
des messagères de paix de concorde sur
la scène internationale pour éviter
cette montée des nationalismes dans
laquelle nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite de manière
générale et par tous à des niveaux
extrêmement élevés en europe et on l'a
vu avec le bric site on le verra je
l'espère probablement demain avec notre
allié du fp aux élus à la présidence
autrichienne un mouvement des peuples
qui veulent être entendus contre la
mondialisation débridée contre les
traités de libre échange qui détruisent
l'économie et l'industrie
interrogé au sujet de l'obamacare le
président et lui revient sur sa promesse
de supprimer totalement cette loi qui a
donné une assurance santé à 22 millions
d'américains
elle sera abrogée et remplacée ils
eurent un grand système d'assurance
santé qui coûtera beaucoup moins cher
voire à new york une centaine de
personnes arpentent la ville en passant
par la tour trump et times square
nous allons retrouver notre pays
patch mais vraiment n'ayez pas peur
l'élection vient d'avoir lieu
seul vrai et il faut nous donner du lait
dont le territoire de donald trump est
une pierre en réalité supplémentaires
dans l'émergence d'un nouveau monde qui
a vocation à remplacer un ordre ancien
para côté promesses donald trump a
confirmé qu'il nommerait à la cour
suprême des juges anti avortement est
favorable au port d'armes à feu
en revanche il ne va pas remettre en
cause le mariage homosexuel
paris veut vraiment construire ce mur
oui certains députés républicains ont
dit qu'il pourrait s'agir d'une barrière
vous accepteriez barrières pour
certaines zones on pourrait mettre une
clôture
mais pour d'autres un mur serait plus
approprié je suis vraiment bon pour tout
ça ça s'appelle la construction
il renonce à son salaire de président
quelques 400 mille dollars annuels
donald trump dont la fortune personnelle
est estimée à 3,7 milliards de dollars
ne percevra que le dollar symbolique
exigé par la loi
[Musique]